e arresto per non aver ancora messo mi
piace questo video clicca subito non mi
piace per è liberata
ciao a tutti in italia oggi nuova
challenge non sparare all'ingrediente
sbagliato challenge oppure spara
all'ingrediente giusto challenge per uno
slide cosa tematica noi abbiamo la
nostra macchinetta in cui passeranno
tutti gli ingredienti abbiamo colpire
quelli giusti e non quelli sbagliati
ogni volta che colpire un ingrediente
possiamo aggiungerlo alla destrezza
toloi
formeremo lo slime e alla fine vincerà
chi avrà lo slime più bello tutti furono
qualcosa in più potrete votare se ho
vinto io passi ha vinto vitale siete
pronti per partire col coro the caldo e
iniziamo subito lancia le eta parte già
noto vicini o quattro proiettili a testa
tutta uno ce l'hai dentro più alti 3 ok
pronti si parlerà di back end
la colla
che milan
là dove prima da basta
bene ecco
[Musica]
bravo anche tre gol a milanello
proiettile in testa prende colorante
rosa
ma basta ancora
bravissimo ho beccato il colorante rosa
e la colla quindi posso iniziare ad
aggiungergli all news live e dunque
aggiungo la colla o dopo spero di
beccare la schiuma da barba
magari le palline qualcosa all adozione
è stata brava colpite alla fine il
colorante nota vi immaginate se peccato
per sbaglio il colorante verde o dio
vediamo vediamo che brilla cervello si
fortunata se già un punto ben capito se
io riesco a prendere qualcosa di giallo
in auto quando ha piazzato quindi
probabilmente ritirare a prenderne 4
non credo proprio quarto ridiamo e
allora la cosa
quello che due piani in verde quell'ora
perché non so perché hai voluto prendere
i giorni cosa vuol dire giudizio vuol
dire che puoi scegliere tu un qualsiasi
ingrediente alimenti secchi e quelli che
ho sparato quindi l'anno ne farò la
colla già da giorni e giorni di disegni
quindi cerco la colla con stagione
ecco perché se no almeno siamo sicuri
che ci abbiamo qualcosa la colla e poi e
poeti è capitato il colorante verde il
colorante verde come tuo team propria
roba il mio team
allora abbiamo messo la colla colorante
verde lo mettiamo subito questo lei in
verde
finalmente poi dopo spero di prendere
altri jolly così posso aggiungere tutto
quello che voglio vedremo se anche i
giorni cattivo
senza l'utilizzo di cattivo che sento io
io tanto il verde l'ho già preso quindi
non puoi scegliere penso siamo prendo io
e charlie cattivo allora cosa diciamo
cosa ci aggiungiamo cadetto se lo
procura ha chiesto che vediamo adesso
beccare l'inter
riprendiamo azione
[Applauso]
a meno che una nazione
benissimo bisoli è la chiave
e allora ecco qua ho preso un jolly e la
nazione allora con i giovani o nei
giorni metto la schiuma da barba anche
perché era difficile dove cari non
essere scarpe carla la prossima volta e
quindi mette schiusa barba riproverebbe
carne dopo ci prova fascia profumato nel
provare diventerà ancora più chiaro è un
grosso passo del libro antico sembrano
mecapix bubble e poi metterla l'azione
profumata e preghiera
e così diventa elastico e profumato
penso poi in vantaggio ha detto vitale
[Musica]
devi provare a recuperare adesso
cercare niente abbiamo preso iscritte
niente allora per carlton glitter e
jolly allora bisogna prendere allora
come ha scelto i glitter rossi degli
stone che li sto subito aggiungeremo
visto che sommati pone albero di natale
ho fatto lo slide natalizia ma semmai
brutale e vitale che cosa e come jolly
do mettere la schiuma da barba per farlo
più afoso al massimo la barba c'è
l'amico gay dopo riesco a prendere gli
altri glitter li metto color oro così
che non ci abbiamo le palline rosse
girocolli natale con bella un bello
slime natalizio che bello quanto mi
piace questa giallo si divertente
sparare degli ingredienti e che la pensi
e ricevente pioli mela tuoi su con
l'adozione in più ma io non lo voglio la
lezione è il mio ultimo tour mi
disperiamo di peccare qualcosa di buono
ma come fare blind gioca cattivo cattivo
cattivo azzurri poi fallire
[Musica]
il joker cattivo e quindi posso
scegliere io che ingredienti mette nello
slum di vitale non sbagliarla e poi il
jolly
allora come jolly uso le palline voglio
farlo un po francioso so perché non
riuscivo a prenderle e cosa voi ho
scritto ma ci faccio un bel haj carica
e per svantaggiare il figlio che cosa
buttare il pacchetto ingerente da
aggiungo io direttamente un'idea
aggiungo il nero h forti diventa grigia
così impari tutte le volte che mi hai
fatto diventare uno slang verde o di un
colore brucato sai qualcosa dopo tanto
che mi ha messo così tanto così posso
fare il kalac si sta diventando vero
papà
quindi tu devi cercare di salvarlo col
tuo ultimo turno altrimenti non verrà
questo colore grigio dove il verde sta
comunque tenendo ciononostante corrotto
le rimanenti lotterer il werther pure
mani su quest'ultimo tornate 30 per
cercare di imitarlo devo prendere
cli car l'inter quanti più possibili
quindi secondo me colorante colloqui
salvarla con colore più bello non lo so
i nomi lascerebbe avuto dovere verde
tanti tanti gritta viene poi qualcosa
magari con qualche jolly che adesso ci
pensa proprio turno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che cosa le gare per i cazzi tuoi soldi
per pranzi o meglio questo colore perché
diventa uno forse di verde acqua se con
fermezza muro e quindi ho fatto un
favore no perché io lo volevo perso il
primato che corrono nome inizia in
questo joker indovinate un po che cosa
potrò mai prendere non potrò prendere il
colorante acrilico verde nei fatti noi e
io lo prendo
perché andrò a prendere invece tra i
coloranti il colore
visto che poteva esso giusto un paio di
gocce io metterò un paio di gocce ha
lavorato così tanto sarei messo
tantissimo che si vede da allora dopo
aver messo il colorante alimentare verde
rosa infinita la chiamò a girare fra
chimiche di meter rosa rosa rimandi mi
fermano in rosa e indovina neanche
colore uscirà un gancio top rosa rimane
rosa verde ma era stato iniettato un
rosa antico si vedono capire il
flessibile maledetto sappi che mi vedi
che la prossima
e tu cosa vuoi mettere nel tuo io voglio
i glitter perché li ho presi quali poi
le voglio utili per dorati e grip era
raggiunta ti evita con luccicanti che è
arrivato un pacco dell'amazon brent si
dà quindi e dentro ci sono tantissimi
glitter esoterico
un giorno mi è arrivato giusto in tempo
apriamo c'è scritto ai box un box
pesante ci stanno tutti c'è solo cibo ma
[Applauso]
[Musica]
eric l'inter era finalmente che la
parola 6 diretta di vitale del gioco e
slide di natale battiamo ancora novembre
show con la pall
un po mi dispiace non averli aperti
prima solo uno ne puoi scegliere però è
ora vuoi certo ne posso scendere saluto
ai o anche i gialli che deve aggiungere
due di natale voglio oro e poi è oggi e
di euro in pochi effetto faranno
non so se dio per luci che tutti prima e
adesso mettiamo anche gritta adorare
troppo in albero di natale questo è bene
possiamo rimettere a posto
ne viene un po come diventa secondo
spike lee fisci si vedono da è carino ma
mio dolore non sarebbe stato bellissimo
live albero di natale non è dovuto il
claim natalizio di secondo avrebbe
rovinato il mio soprattutto a stage
ora andiamo ad attivarli e poi glieli
facciamo vedere e poi potrete motore se
vincevi care o se vinco io allora ecco
ai news live con sul senso e vedere il
rosa ha resistito non è diventato verde
è un rosa un po rosa antico è scaduto e
zucchero allungabile però anche grazie
alla lazio ne fa un bel po di suoni e
rimasto un pochino e non lo volevo
attivare troppo a ficarazzi
ma che prosegue l'architetto di molti
schifezza sempre un curioso di vedere il
tuo io ho colpito gli ingredienti che
volevo neanche quelli che volevo per te
[Applauso]
dovevo mettere più nero del tuo prato
comunque fa un sacco di sono irrilevanti
io pochi pitt che fronti quindi datevi
prodotto da un'amica che l'aspetto e
persone vediamo quello digitale
lo slime di natale cioè questo colore
bello verde tipico natalizio e anche se
si vede poco ci sono tutti i click qui
il vero sì sì certo che si vedono tutti
questi glik rossi dorati e d'argento
sono bellissimi sono kerger argento per
questo fatto poi ci sono poi con la
schiuma da barba alla reso supersoffici
allungabile è bellissimo e adesso ve lo
presento vi faccio sentire i suoni
perché uno slide fantastico e con mano
morta è tornata l'amore della famiglia
ta
[Musica]
ai rumori non ci siamo tanto però il
booking e molto meglio di quello di
anime abbiamo fatto la focaccina slime
di nenad e focaccina e niente e questo è
il mio me ti chiama questo si chiama lo
slime di natale ovviamente e invio che
non me li dai detto che tanta fantasia è
tuo è lo slime scaduto rosa scaduto ma
si guarda dai bettino fianco al mio né
bellissimo e vediamo anzi due
claudio studente preferite di platì time
crisis live
i ragazzi infatti ultimati infatti
hashtag il classic noi ragazzi vi lascio
qua il sondaggio in cui potete votare se
ti ho vinto io oggi ho vinto vitale
fateci sapere nei commenti che a persone
volete vedere in cui spariamo per la
colpisse michelin bottigliate sicure che
altre zone spara con la colpì si salda
in scheletro potremo colpire consegnarsi
nei commenti le dette specie di più noi
saremo anco ricino andremo al milan e
ora vi lasciamo 4 parte business
critical e proprio delle nostre sale il
video divertenti reazioni live cliccate
tutto quello che preferite